one of our favorite guest sees here
kindly to provide the insider
information of the Honda inside a report
on the Rich Eisen show he is our friend
Pro Football Hall of Famer Tony Dungy
from NBC sports football night in
America and more how are you coach hey
rich how are you I'm great so what do
you think's going through Anthony Lynn's
mind is quarterback who is a Hall of
Fame credentials is going to turn 38 in
a couple of weeks
you're now four and seven going into a
bye week and you're a quarterback just
threw his 14th interception of the year
what do you think's going on with
Anthony LAN in his quarterback right now
no he is wondering if it's getting close
to the time to turn the page they've had
all these one score losses and they'll
look at the whole first part of the
season over the Bible we can say you
know what to play here it has made this
play if we could kick this field goal we
be right in the playoff hunt so do I
write it out with Phillips if we made on
the streak you're probably not going to
make the playoffs now what is next year
look like those are all the things that
are going through your mind at this
plant and yeah I tell you what he's got
to be getting close to making that
decision right this year
turning the Terron Taylor and see what
he's got on the bunch I don't think that
I think they'll write out the rest of
the year with Philip and now they owe
that to him you know but in anthem in
Lance's mind he's thinking all right
2020 are we going to have a new
quarterback and if so what does this
offense going to look like I was gonna
build it I know they had high hopes
going and I had high out for them I
thought they're gonna be one of the top
five games and I'll be and all of these
one score losses you know it just it
takes the heart out of it Tony Dungy
here on the Rich Eisen show so I mean do
you have a conversation with with Philip
and I mean how do you tell a guy who's
who's been there done that does no
football inside and out know what she
can't do what he's doing how do you
communicate with him with after
something like that I think you just
come out of this vine and you say what
you know we're gonna try to win every
game here in December and we're gonna
let it all go and see what happens and
then at the end of the year we're going
to make some decisions and yeah you got
to
I know you want to be back next year you
want to be here this is your team and
hopefully it will remain this but we've
got to do that in these last five five
games Tony Dungy here on the Rich Eisen
show okay so your your best team through
11 weeks you've seen a lot would be
which team
neither context change week in and week
out two weeks ago I thought it was the
same
I just thought their defense was playing
at a high level Brees was back they were
going to get camara and cook back and
and I just don't pave or the team and
Atlanta went into New Orleans and we'll
it took them apart and dismantled it off
and I said wow that was shocking to me
and then Baltimore every week they just
seemed to get a little bit better I was
worried about their their defense but
they played better right now over the
last three weeks no one's playing better
than Baltimore so if you had to win a
game right now that you had to say I'm
gonna take this team to win this weekend
it would be Baltimore I would take
Baltimore right right now as we speak I
think they're playing the most complete
there often is really a handful for
people to absorb in one week and they
put a lot of pressure on people and
defensively they're making enough plays
and putting enough pressure on with
their front I would take em in a one-day
knockout right now and then the NFC team
that you'd put up against them would be
who who's best suited Wow I think we'll
find out Sunday night I don't want a
high power game you know go for it let's
go San Francisco Green Bay I'm not crazy
about Green Bay's defense but Aaron
Rodgers seems to have running and going
with him now and that has made him into
a better player they've got pass rusher
so when they do put up points and they
get ahead they can really shut the door
on you but the problem I think Green Bay
is going to have a team like San
Francisco that could run the ball at him
and use that time and possession they
can I think Green Bay can be had if
you've got a strong running game I mean
isn't it amazing that in this day and
age
of spread amount five wide who needs a
fullback right that two teams that are
performing so well are running the ball
down your throat in Baltimore and San
Francisco do you think we are
maybe witnessing the finally a stemming
of the tide of just winging it all over
the lot Tony well I think it's two
things that really understand what
football is all about now and everybody
is coming up with these situational
defenders and situational pass rushers
and defending this red and five wide
that you come with a powerful running
attack it is so different and what
people have had to deal with it catches
a lot of people totally off-guard and
people aren't ready for Green Bay is
really you know they went out and got
the two Smith's and they say Dave we're
gonna be able to rest the passer and
they can do that and and Chicago you
know had that great pass rust but now
when they're playing close games and
people are running the ball at them like
the Rams did the other night
it's different and I don't think people
are ready to handle this Tony Dungy Hall
of Fame Tony Dungy Hall of Famer here on
the Rich Eisen show in the Honda insider
report your MVP through 11 weeks would
be poo it's one of those quarterbacks
and I kind of changed every week right
now I'd have to say Lamar Jackson no one
thought no one had Baltimore as the best
team in the league week one no one
thought that and Lamar has been the
difference they've got out of coach
who's really done a great job I think of
molding to his talents but he's been a
difference weekend in week out and when
he was out in Seattle and they beat the
Seahawks in the tough venue
he was the difference-maker so I'd have
to say right now if I was voting that's
who I would vote for you know it really
is amazing I mean what he has done is
truly remarkable and we're still yet
many wondering if it is sustainable
January comes how will it be different
from last year with what the Chargers
did to that offense in their house in
the playoffs Tony well Lamar was born
mature and he understands and they've
also had to hear more
him and fine-tuning this offense coming
up with answers for things like what the
charges last year but it's still too
early to see if it is sustainable we can
go back a few years and we were all
gushing about Robert Griffin this time
his rookie year and gosh what is the
league going to do to handle him and
rein him in and I was thinking about it
the defensive coordinator what can you
play this guy who can run 75 yards if
you play man coverage and all of these
things and you know those quarterbacks
if you're gonna run that much you're
still going to get hit and what kind of
toll is that going to take but I think
the difference between Robert Griffin
situation and Lamar Jackson all support
methods embraced this Mike Shanahan
still had his system and he still wanted
to run that Ozzie Newsome told the
Ravens and when we dressed this guy we
have to sell out we get these type of
lineman we've got to get these type of
running back we've got to get big strong
receivers who can block more than that
we've got to get receivers who aren't
going to complain if they only catch 30
passes the whole year because it's going
to be tailored to the tight ends and the
power peels and that so everybody has
bought into this they have put all of
these collars running plays in and it's
it's a handful on the NFL now Lamar's
got to stay healthy and he's so far he
has done it he shows no signs of wearing
down but I said that about Robert
Griffin his first day too Tony you were
there on the set Sunday night on NBC and
we all saw all true Biscay Mitchell true
Brisky struggle again for the Bears with
the exception of a 12-play 80-yard Drive
to start the second half supposedly
after he had hurt his hip and it just
only supposedly got worse and the reason
why I keep hammering that word
supposedly is he didn't finish the game
and we were all wondering if Matt Negi
had actually pulled his quarterback
we're now being told by the Bears that
it was injury related and that if he is
healthy
he is the starter how do you feel the
situation with Maggie and true Biscay is
going to wind up in Chicago I think they
believe in mr. burski I think the city
is against him right now I think
he still has the back because his team
has teammate the front office so I think
he's going to be okay to continue to
move forward we were watching the game
in the studio and when el Michael said
you know we get word from the Bears PR
that they don't know what what happened
no report to me that was a mistake
yes that was truly being pulled from
injury under situation if I was Matt
Nagy I would have told our PR department
he's injured hip injury that's why he's
out if that out to the newspaper I'm
into the booth because I don't want any
speculation that's taking him out
because of performance you got to know
you know that's not what you normally do
but in this situation you got to nip all
that in the bud and you've got a strake
we still have confidence in our
quarterback now is that something that
happens on a sideline you're coach
you're in the middle of a game you know
obviously you just gave up a touchdown
the put you down by two scores which is
a monumental gap for you to try and and
bridge because of how poor your offense
is going and then somebody comes up to
you and says to you why is true Biscay
out and you have to deal with a member
of the PR staff during a game is that
what happens if you're a first-year
coach or a second-year coach maybe
you're not thinking that way you're just
trying to figure out how you're going to
score twice and get back in this game
but if you have been in this at all and
if you've been in the Chicago media
market especially and the way the season
has gone from it you have to think about
that and you can't say you know I'll
deal with this later I'll deal with this
on Monday news you know because that's
what we're all thinking
watching the game it's been why is he
taking mr. burski out now and you do
have to get ahead of the game in certain
situation Tony Dungy here on the Rich
Eisen shown the few minutes I have left
with you have you had any communication
at all with Colin Kaepernick Tony Dungy
I have not our station and we tried to
reach out to Colin when we were going on
our pregame show on Sunday and we had
some people that talk to his
representatives and his agent
but we have not had
any contact with him and I think that's
what everybody's waiting to hear you
know let us hear your voice Colin let's
be able to ask you some questions and
have you give us some answers and that
would be nice it really would
well I mean III think it just appears it
cuz again I I have no communication with
his team either but it does appear that
Kaepernick's stance if you will is that
I am Who I am the fact that I have the
quarterback skills to be in the NFL is
enough to give me a job and I'm gonna be
Who I am and that should be fine for you
I don't need to conform to the NFL that
my credentials as a quarterback having
been in the Superbowl before and my
credentials what I can do with my arm in
my legs right now is so far superior to
some of the people that are getting a
shot it shouldn't matter so why why does
he have to say something or communicate
something to make it seem like he would
conform to the NFL is basically what I'm
asking yeah and I understand his point
of view I think all of what you just
said is absolutely true but I know if
I'm a head coach and I'm trying to sign
a player anybody I'm going to get those
questions answered are you going to fit
into my locker room and how I do things
and whether it's Colin Kaepernick or
anybody else so if I don't get those
questions answered I'm not going to sign
anyone normally that's not even an issue
guys want to play and if we have a
workout and I want to bring you in hey I
need to talk to you most guys are ready
to go and I can see Colin point well how
do I know that this is real hard I know
you really want to talk to me you don't
you just have to trust me
so do you think this is a bridge that
can be divided Tony and you're kind of a
perfect person to ask this because you
were B if I recall correctly you
counseled Michael Vick when he was at
Leavenworth and Michael Vick was was in
jail
michael vick exactly and and and you
were there to help bridge a divide that
now has michael vick on TV michael vick
is a correspondent for my show and I
felt the grandees been on this show if
that could be somehow a divided bridge
put together after what Vick was in jail
for how is it is do you think this could
be put together between Kaepernick and
the NFL for an NFL team to have him out
there talking I think it could happen
I'm skeptical that it would happen in
Michael situation Michael knew that he
did something wrong and he had to make
amends and he told everyone that he was
ready to do anything to make amends
Colin doesn't feel he's done anything
wrong so I don't think he it's just what
you're talking about why do I have to go
the extra mile I should just be able to
demonstrate my skill and that you know
that's enough so that's where I think
the difference is and that's why I think
it's going to be dicey to ever get this
resolved yeah I hear you because again
Colin hasn't been a convicted of
anything it's easy isn't committed any
crime he's just been very outspoken and
it just is something that I last for you
on this subject is what did what advice
would you give him if you did have some
sort of moment to to sit down with him
you know don't change your convictions
you don't have to change anything but
you are going to have to show people
that hey I really want to play in this
league and I'm willing to do my part as
a player and a teammate I'm willing to
accept and that's what I don't know are
you willing to accept any role at this
point that hey you may not compete for a
starting quarterback situation I'm and
that's what Michael did Andy Reid
brought him in he was the backup to
Donovan McNabb there were no promises no
hey you're going to compete for the
starting job in so many months we're
signing you were giving you an
opportunity he said thank you and he
took it
oh that's you know what what Colin is
going to have to let people know that
he's ready to do
then will it still work we don't know
because there are a number teams that
would just say no I don't want the
headache I'm not going to sign them let
someone else do that but it was the same
in microstates he probably had twenty
teams that were not interested but all
it takes is one Tony I really appreciate
the time sorry about your Golden Gophers
final game I'm thinking Big Ten
championship but it's been a great year
it's been a great year so far and I
assume you have had communication with
PJ flack right and and have you
connected with during the season but
I've been watching and sending my best
and kind of trying to stay positive and
really the boat that's right Tony thanks
again for everything I always appreciate
our chats and I'd love to have you on
certainly before the end of the season
well right back at you thanks that's
Tony Dungy at Tony Dungy on Twitter for
more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR Live or download the Rich Eisen
show app